هذا بلد محارب ، أرض
قديمة تبدو مصممة للصراع والآن
اليمن تمزق مرة أخرى تقول الأمم المتحدة
إنها على بعد خطوة واحدة من المجاعة
بسبب الحرب ولكن في رحلة 4000 كيلومتر
عبر المناطق الأكثر تضررًا
وجدنا أشخاصًا أبرياء يقتربون  حتى
الموت من قبل حكومة الحوثيين المتمردة
التي تتلاعب بالمساعدات بينما
حاول مسؤولو الأمم المتحدة منعهم ، وجدنا
دليلاً على ذلك في جميع أنحاء شمال
اليمن أولاً في قضية بوني بعد خمس ساعات
بالسيارة من العاصمة.
أو ألف
ريال وهو يشتري الطعام لنا ويذهب إلى
المنزل ولكن لا يوجد مال لشراء
حفاضات الأطفال أو الأدوية لماذا
تعتقد أنك لا تحصل على مساعدة
هنا ، فهم لا يصلون إلينا هنا اعتادوا
على إعطائنا  الحبوب والطحين
لكنهم رفضوا بعد ذلك إعطائها لأي شخص
لا يعطوننا أي شيء
بالفعل اعتمد الفقراء القذرون هنا على
معونات الأمم المتحدة لكنهم توقفوا عندما
اكتشف برنامج الغذاء العالمي  أن
الإمدادات كانت مفقودة ، لذلك في هذه
القرية هناك بعض سوء التغذية
والناس يقيمون لدرجة أنهم لا
يحصلون على أي مساعدة ، لماذا
اعتادوا إعطاء الآباء كيسًا من حبوب
الزيت وأشياء أخرى كل شهر ، وهذا
توقف منذ شهرين.  لا أعرف سبب
وجود أشخاص في أعلى المستويات يعرفون سبب
طرحها على
أعلى المستويات ، لقد كان علينا بالتأكيد في
العديد من المواقف أن نقول للسلطات المحلية
أنك لا تسمح لنا بالدخول إلى هناك ،
ولا يمكننا متابعة هذه المشكلة  لهذا
السبب اضطررنا إلى المواقف
التي قلنا فيها إذا لم تسمح لنا بالدخول
إذا لم تسمح لنا بالقيام بوظائفنا بشكل صحيح ،
فلن نتمكن من الاستمرار في
هذا هو Aslam the  مُنعت الأمم المتحدة من
الوصول إلى هذه المنطقة وأوقفت توزيع المواد الغذائية
لأنه لا يمكن
مراقبتها على بعد أميال قليلة فقط من
خط المواجهة.
بقيادة تحالف مسلح من قبل ال  ه الولايات المتحدة
وآخرون ضد المتمردين الحوثيين المدعومين من إيران
ما نطلبه من
الآخرين وعندما نحصل على حصتنا من
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ، أعيد
للناس ما أدين به ولكننا لم نحصل على
أي شيء من برنامج الغذاء العالمي منذ
شهرين  ليس لدينا أي شيء الآن ، لذا فإن الأمم المتحدة
تحرم الأشخاص المستضعفين مرة أخرى من المساعدة
لأن حكومة الحوثيين
لن تسمح بالوصول والمراقبة المستقلة
بالقرب من مخيمات اللاجئين التي
تكافح هذه العيادة للتعامل
مع إصابة هذا الطفل بالرئة التي
يقول الأطباء إنها نتيجة مباشرة لذلك.
سوء التغذية ، يبلغ من العمر عامًا تقريبًا ،
لكنه يبلغ من العمر ثلاثة
أشهر ، هؤلاء الأطفال هم ضحايا
حلقة مفرغة يتضورون جوعًا
بسبب حصار الميناء الذي
يمدهم به ، وتحويل حكوماتهم الحوثية المتمردة
ما تحصل عليه من مساعدات قليلة
في اليمن الآن كل شخص تقريبًا يعاني
من نقص في التغذية ليس فقط
مشكلة بين النازحين والمجتمع المضيف
لدينا أيضًا حتى نحن
الموظفون أطفالنا  في الوطن ،
يعاني الحوثيون من سوء التغذية ، ويحاصرون
وصولهم إلى العالم الخارجي بعد أن توقفت
هجمات التحالف على هذا المنفذ
الرئيسي لبياناتها
منذ أن فرض التحالف الذي يقوده الرصين
حصارًا على هذا الميناء وهاجمه
من الجو ، فقام بحوالي 800 مليون.
قيمة الأضرار بالدولار نصف
كمية الطعام والمواد الأخرى
التي تدخل الميناء ودمر
حوالي 60٪ من طاقته. الفكرة
بالطبع هي محاولة خنق
قدرة نظام الحوثي على البقاء.
منظور الحوثي للسيطرة على كمية محدودة
من الإمدادات خاصة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالطعام يعني أن لديك سيطرة
على كل شيء في العاصمة صنعاء ،
وتنفي حكومة الحوثيين هذا بشكل
أساسي يقولون إنك
مسيطر للغاية وأنك تستخدم
هذا من أجل  لكسب الأصدقاء سياسياً في
جميع أنحاء البلاد باستخدام المساعدات الخارجية
لكسب الأصدقاء لكسب التأثير السياسي
لديك تياننا الهائل الذي قلته
يمكن وصفه بأنه غير دقيق  تحدث أخطاء
أحيانًا ولكن هذا لا يعني
أو لا يمثل سياسة من جانبنا ،
فنحن سعداء بأي مساعدة
تصل إلى المواطنين لأن هؤلاء المواطنين
هم مصدر قوتنا ودعمنا وهم
عاصمتنا في هذه الحرب ولكن هنا
يصر مسؤولو المساعدة على أن الطعام  تم
تسليحه بدون طعام مجاني من
العالم الخارجي ، ستكافح حكومة الحوثيين من
أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة خطط الأمم المتحدة
لإطعام 12 مليونًا هذا العام معظمهم في
مناطق الحوثيين
، فأنت لست قلقًا من وجودك هنا ،
فقد تطيل أمد الحرب
بالتأكيد أن العاملين في المجال الإنساني ليسوا
سياسيين  نحن هنا لإبقاء الناس
على قيد الحياة ، وتقع مسؤولية إنهاء
الصراع في أيدي الأشخاص
الذين يقودون هذا الصراع العالق
في وسط النساء والأطفال هنا
يكافحون مع الجوع في حرب حيث
تتجاهل الفصائل اليمنية القوية
مسؤوليتها تجاه نفسها.  الناس
ويطالبون الأجانب بتقديم المساعدة
لدعمهم